over the weekend on Saturday minding my
own business and I get kind of a
threatening video email okay now I get
those a lot not a big deal it's part of
the game but this threatening video
email that I got was sent to me by a mr.
Hugh Jackman yes Hugh Jackman sent me a
video that kind of weirded me out a
little bit if you don't mind I'd like to
show it to you you tell me if I'm being
paranoid and crazy all right this is the
video he sent me take a look Kevin I
know you're doing a lot of shows
traveling around the world lots of them
like you've been everywhere around the
world except Australia like it's almost
like you going out of your way not to go
to Australia and assignment and I just
you know because we're mates I just want
you to know that it's been noticed
first of all I didn't know Hugh Jackman
was in prison yeah it's like it's like
he said I want to make a video for Conan
let's go out to my murder shed yeah but
you know I looked into it there's an old
rule in show business when Hugh Jackman
tells you to do something you do it you
have to he's Hugh Jackman right
he's like a quadruple threat right he's
a king of show business that's why I've
been scrambling for two days so that
tonight I could announce ladies and
gentlemen I'm going to Australia
thank you thank you I love it I love it
what an American crowd cheers that I'm
leaving now I'm gonna leave this
Thursday night February 14th miss
Valentine's Day sweetie and then I
arrived in Sydney Saturday morning while
I'm there and I get out I'm gonna meet
all the people I'm gonna visit Hugh
Jackman in prison I'm also doing a live
stand-up show on February 20th at
Sydney's State Theater that's gonna be a
lot of fun and it's all gonna be part of
my next Conan Without Borders episode
Conan in Australia Australia I'm gonna
be out and around you can follow our
adventures on the team cocoa Facebook or
Instagram pages you can see what I'm up
to as it's happening Liz Lerman I really
think it's gonna be a great trip
don't do it counted I'm sorry who said
that I did don't go to Australia Conan
unless you want to die
okay that's absurd I've heard Australia
is actually a beautiful fun place what
are you talking about yeah it is until
you die from being kills okay look I
know there's a lot of dangerous animals
in Australia but I really think I'm
gonna be fine
no you won't trust me every single
animal in Australia is deadly animals
like the saltwater crocodile the Eastern
brown snake in the Corman Death Adder
you know what's so scary about the
Corman Death Adder Conan no wait it's
common anything scarier or the really
common Death Adder and the oh my god
they're everywhere Death Adder
okay fine I'll just be sure to avoid
snakes easy huh it's not just the snakes
that are deadly Conan you better look
out for the ruled it up koala you look
pleased you of staring at his girlfriend
and he'll kick your ass think there's
any such thing as a roided-up co-op but
I hope you don't run into the kangaroo
with a ninja hiding in his pants oh the
warm back with a machine gun and look
out for the faking a leg injury so I can
lure you into his van toad
don't help that toad load that chair
into the van Conan don't do it I'm not I
wouldn't if I saw a toad with a look out
look out for the air-breathing playing
dead shark that's just a photo of a dead
shark that's what the air-breathing
playing dead shark wants you to think
Conan all right wait a minute okay if I
see any dead sharks I'll stay away Oh
platypus oh those are harmless nope is
the world's only venomous venomous
mammals
what's even more dangerous is the
plaited dog the platter Gator the
platter Puig and the planted platter of
deviled egg what's that what's a platy
platter of deviled eggs
just imagine Conan you're in the air
Beck sweating in the hot Sun just
craving some deviled egg I was never
craved that suddenly there it is
gorgeous platter
paprika sprinkled deviled eggs hmm yeah
I don't think that's gonna happen the
little bits of pickles glistening in the
Sun you've got the egg thirst it's gross
it's just gross no one's gonna want to
eat that well your parts from the hot
Sun you've gotta have one of those dents
gritty deviled eggs
now you reach the one I know no you've
been bitten the venom of the planted
platter of deviled eggs begins working
you don't have long but wait there's
hope there's a paramedic okay there's a
paramedic just there's a paramedic just
hanging out randomly in the outback yeah
you're saved
wait nope it's a paramedic ranch Allah
idiot it is now your name your Australia
will kill you
alright enjoy a tree alright I'd send me
a lot of fun I'm looking towards good
thank you very much we got a great show
right one more thing
why go one more thing what invisible
bees
you